we want to be exposed to this consumer
growth in this part of the world where
we aren't yet and we're going to take a
risky leap of faith that we're going to
be able to survive in the regulatory
environment and that our shareholders
are not going to you know be very
concerned that we're changing our
business model they said we want to be a
part of this growth the minute those big
multinationals or when when GM started
investing in auto plants in Russia or
when when when Lennar and some of the
big home builders started investing in
Brazil and investing in essentially
building homes for the new middle class
coming up in the rest of the world this
is this is the exciting part about our
industry right now which is where yeah
this is I think our conversation to tie
a thread around where we've been talking
to the last few minutes is we've seen
this before at other times in investment
history and we've seen it in other
places where you had a consumption trend
that was very exciting and big
sophisticated players came into a small
pool and right now it's still kind of a
small pool not only because of the size
of the investments in the companies but
it's made smaller because the regulatory
environment is very restrictive and it
keeps people out and has kept out a lot
of these big players but they're they're
coming they're gonna be here someone's
opinion me contradict yours what is my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we and what is the
nature of this reality
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don Sakia we're on site at the
beautiful new West summit the cannabis
tech conference we are now gonna be
talking with Timothy Seymour yeah how
are you good to be here it's Ledger's
were coming now I bet huh
what an event yeah and what a panel you
were just moderating as well
it was exciting it's it it couldn't be
probably always felt like this but it
couldn't be a more interesting time to
be talking about investing when you've
completely done a 180 in terms of
sentiment on hey let me throw every
dollar I have into this high-growth area
when in fact a lot of money's not been
returned and won't ever come back so
interesting times to be an investor
because I think it's it's the the reason
for us all to be here has never been
more exciting and there is execution and
there are companies doing great things
and there's also a lot of companies that
just have not executed took a lot of
money in and will never fulfill the
promise Wow and yeah sorry about that I
have a very sober start to the day
Silver Stars yeah and it actually kind
of also reminds me of like 10 years ago
with the decentralization movement as
well and coke currencies because we want
to leverage the technology of
decentralization and we want to leverage
the technology of cannabis right for
ascension right and if we're using it to
try and just make the quick buck along
the way it's it's so let's jump into
this um Tim's background so interesting
founder and chief investment officer of
see more assets management and you've
been just 22 years of investment
experience before fully manager I mean
let's talk about dating myself okay you
got you got your young with age yes
experience is the wisdom so let's jump
into your big picture understanding of
what is going on you started taking us
down this path yeah what are you
currently seeing happening so and I'll
frame it within my lens and my lane
investor and when I show up at a great
event like this and I talked to
investors that are also either new to
the asset class I try to point out that
as you referenced either with crypto or
maybe it was in the late 90s with
dot-com but my my background is in
emerging markets so new asset classes if
you will and it's a case where some of
the dynamics in terms of the size of the
market the lack of liquidity newer
companies corporate governance risks all
balanced against this wonderful exciting
growth story for this you know not just
post-prohibition blah blah blah that
everybody can talk about but really
truly a consumption story that is going
to be staggering and and people tend to
throw darts a little bit about the size
of the addressable market but we all
know when you add in adult medical
wellness lifestyle crossover ancillary
all the different elements of support I
mean there's a there's a lot of people
in this country that are going to be
working in this industry in some
capacity and that's so exciting because
it look for those of us that have been
part of the early stages here there is a
small sense of not only is this a very
viable interesting exciting area but
there is a level of social
responsibility there is a level of I
think and not just trying to make the
buck at all costs and and that's not
every company in every investor and
every leader but there's a lot of that
here and that's great but but but it
wouldn't be happening if there wasn't a
huge opportunity for for the addressable
market across multiple demographic
groups across multiple geographies
across multiple product classes so for
me I come about this as a guy that's
used to investing in new asset classes I
lived in Russia invested in in emerging
markets and in Brazil and in China in
the earlier days before a lot of people
were investing in those markets so a lot
of the a lot of my instincts for
investing in those markets are the ones
that actually work pretty well here Wow
so you actually had background of seeing
emerging markets in BRIC the listened to
you
so yeah you had that great time with
seeing emerging
markets build up in BRIC countries and
also be able to again just see the
vision of what was going on from kind of
like a big top-down macro perspective
and and see what failed what succeeded
and so now I want to see then what where
maybe some of those similarities and
what was happening in the past couple of
decades with emerging markets and also
with what like we talked about there's
this in there's this spiritual dependent
like we have to be we have to have a
deep ethic so there's some
accountability accountability socially
there's got to be a kind of doing
regulatory wise and and compliance wise
I mean this there certainly needs to be
adherence to a very strict set of rules
and and the cannabis industry for the
most part companies that have grown up
in this industry have have their DNA is
to be more compliant right I mean people
embrace are embracing the regulatory
environment obviously there's certain of
the parts of the regulatory framework we
want to to change you know to lighten up
on and they include some of the banking
dynamic some of the the capital markets
dynamics some of the the interstate
shipping dynamics but but at the end of
the day these are companies that that I
think are probably embracing it but that
the people that are investing in this
industry so getting back to kind of
we're all part of something I think you
know I think there's some recognition
that there's adherence to a set of
values that are important and and I'm
not just saying this I mean I've been I
go to a lot of conferences and I meet a
lot of investors and it's not shouldn't
be a terrible surprise but that you know
in in the concern Francisco this is this
is a this is a heartbeat part of the
industry and and there's a lot of focus
on doing the right thing and giving
something back while you're taking
something from it and and social justice
and and and and environmental
environmental first you all of it so I
you know that's that's nice but if you
didn't if it doesn't make sense
from an economic perspective and it
doesn't make sense from from really a
pathway to growth it's it's not gonna
work anyway so that they have to be
combined yes yes it's also as you kind
of walk us through this again that's
like macro person
especially on like an emerging market of
cannabis there's a whole bunch of
regulatory stuff I mean with crypto we
also saw a whole bunch of changes now
and regulatory stuff that are gonna be
happening but it's it's like a little
bit different with just like in a sense
like if you're just upgrading like from
like gasoline combustion engines to
electric engines you don't really need
regulatory things a little bit on maybe
incentives of sorts the transition right
bull right but this is completely
different we're talking like you said
shipping across countries we're talking
certain lots of countries still illegal
in those countries so yes so let's talk
about how like yeah what where will
regulatory things have to change
in order to maximize them and you were
talking about there will be so many jobs
that emerge from getting work here in
holding accountability so yeah so let's
take us down like the regulatory well
the regulatory area is one that first of
all needs to to adjust to make companies
have the ability to succeed so that
means adjusting the regulatory framework
as it exists around accounting so how
companies actually record their business
for taxation purposes so you know
section 280a is a part of the tax code
that basically still counts cannabis
producers in the same way as folks that
are creating and producing illicit drugs
and things that are i think
significantly it's fundamentally
different but but what that also means
or people that are involved in federally
illegal industries it could be running
guns it could be anything
and so the tax law says anybody who's
involved in a Schedule one something
cannot subtract cost of goods sold and
have traditional accounting metrics that
allow them to actually be profitable
effectively so so there's a case where
just some of the regulatory need to need
to make it possible for companies that
have a great retail footprint and are
trying to you know operate in sometimes
what's a relatively low margin
environment had the ability to succeed
there's the whole banking dynamic one of
the things we're seeing in the capital
markets today in a big part of our
investor path today was was how it's
it's a painful painful bear market right
now in in the public markets for the
publicly traded stuff a lot of its
Canadian some of them are a lot of more
us frankly because really
also some of these Raley's as well yeah
I mean there's a couple Australians but
but the ability to raise capital in some
of the deepest most sophisticated
capital markets and pools of capital in
the world which is the United States of
America isn't just me waving a flag this
is just a fact
so these are companies that cannot do
that in a traditional way they're very
smart very risk aware investors that are
sophisticated that want to invest in the
sector understand that it's not you know
a straight pathway to to a pot of gold
but understand the but they can't invest
in it because of the federal dynamics so
what that's doing is it's keeping big
pools of capital out of this market and
it means that after an initial burst of
enthusiasm and excitement by high
net-worth and prep private banks and
non-traditional institutions which
raised a lot of money for the industry
those folks are tapped out there's no
new capital coming into the industry
there's been very there's been no new
capital it's come into the industry for
I would argue six to nine months and
you're seeing it in the way these
companies are trading they're trying to
come to market they need growth capital
a lot of these companies are in capex
and OPEX having eight businesses in
within the industry which is inherently
a kind of a high capex growth industry
any industry that's a growth industry is
capital intensive I mean look at Netflix
core still not making money you know so
and it's Netflix so this has put a crimp
on the entire investment landscape and
it's so it's back to the regulatory
framework you're asking me about these
are the things that need to be adjusted
and there was some recent regulation
that went through the house on what's
called the SAFE Act which will give
investors will give companies the
opportunity possibly to at least Bank
normally so to have credit lines to
actually be able to do traditional
payroll to actually keep bank accounts
this is more so that people aren't
walking around with suitcases of cash
and that you know people who are
interesting so Wells and the Bank of
America can have cannabis companies they
think anything they will be able to if
this goes
phase one was getting through the house
cool and and now this bills is going to
be read in the Senate at some point I
think in the fall interesting okay so
the
this uh maybe Anna Macra way this can be
thought of as going from the old codes
as emerging markets erupt is to ask
quickly and also intelligently as
possible adjust to the new codes that
enable the emerging markets actually
rise and succeed and I also liked yeah
all the way from basic accounting stuff
like safe back to all the way up to a
geopolitical like how do you take this
big pool event your money that's really
wanting to get involved and enable it to
get involved so is this usually like the
thing that happens is that it's just
like a peer seen some some of these
phases I would characterize is very
similar so if we're gonna take our same
you know kind of metaphor comparison
into emerging markets week I think we
have seen some of this before an example
for me was when I was living in Russia
the the state gas company Gazprom is the
biggest gas company in the world and and
at a time when investing in natural
resources was a very big investment
trend in the early 2000s there really
dude the financial crisis there was this
sense that you know the world was
growing China was consuming more all
these you know Asian countries and South
American countries and younger
populations Middle Eastern countries
were consuming needed more combined so
anyway people started investing in
commodities back to Russia and decima
Gazprom was one of the most interesting
investments for a lot of global
investors but as a non-resident investor
a non-resident of Russia investing in a
Russian company required a shell and a
structure and a creative solution which
is what's going on here too so you know
my investor is sitting in New York or
sitting in Boston and some of the big
mutual funds or some of the big hedge
funds that are sitting out here in San
Fran or LA you know they're like Tim I
want to UM gas Prime how do I do it we
had to create a legal structure that
allowed them a participation in a row we
set up a Russian company because I
actually worked for a Russian bank now
we don't need to get into the weeds of
this but the point is that ultimately
there was a lot of capital they could
never invest in Russia because a lot of
the state-owned companies you couldn't
invest in there was a
it was a federal dynamic in Russia there
was a time in Russia think about the
friction list is something that we have
it may be safe efficient you have more
efficient yeah and think about think
about if you're a cannabis investor and
you've been watching this industry for a
while and you've been watching how
Canada's certainly had a head start and
in terms of the capital markets arguably
I think probably this area would argue
we we were the ones that started this
industry in a real way in this country
and in in North America but but I
remember where I was the day I heard
Constellation Brands was taking a
majority ownership stake or had the
optionality to do that in canopy growth
I remember where I was I was remembered
looking at the markets I was it was
staggering and shocking I said okay here
we go we're gonna see every major
consumer products company come in
because why wouldn't they yeah and in in
constellations perspective I don't think
this is about THC infused beverages and
an alternative to their beer market I
don't think I think it's more about
diversification of portfolio I think I
think it is I think it's i think i think
constellation is a global consumer
products company that is a very
sophisticated brand and distribution
plane so
back to so then then there's the
reliability the accountability like
totally yeah totally like we're saying
the portfolio but our this they're also
that ethical or moral or spiritual
alignment with ascension as well not
just the buck making well I mean you
know I I feel like we're in my Sunday
school class right now and man I you
know I teach fourth grade Sunday school
by the way yeah I talk about the
Ascension but but but to but the point
I'm making is a couple like
constellation raises the bar for the
entire industry but it also at that time
it drove valuations way higher because
everybody said who's the next one to
come in and of course you know Molson
Coors did a JV with hexo an anhyzer but
did a JV with tilray and so ever some of
the biggest most sophisticated consumer
products companies in the world a lot of
them happening to be associated to the
spirits industry but I've just go back
to my metaphors I remember when when
Telenor which is Norway's largest phone
company decided to buy up gsm basically
sell mobilized
in Eastern Europe and they started
buying them in Russia and they started
buying them in Turkey and and basically
it was again a global multinational
saying we want to be exposed to this
consumer growth in this part of the
world where we aren't yet and we're
going to take a risky leap of faith that
we're going to be able to survive in the
regulatory environment and that our
shareholders are not going to you know
be very concerned that we're changing
our business model they said we want to
be a part of this growth the minute
those big multinationals or when when GM
started investing in auto plants in
Russia or when when when Lennar and some
of the big home builders started
investing in Brazil and investing in
essentially building homes for the new
middle class coming up in the rest of
the world I mean this is this is the
exciting part about our industry right
now which is where yeah this is I think
our conversation to tie a thread around
where we've been talking for the last
few minutes is we've seen this before at
other times in investment history and
we've seen it in other places where you
had a consumption trend that was very
exciting and big sophisticated players
came into a small pool and right now
it's still kind of a small pool not only
because of the size of the investments
in the companies but it's made smaller
because the regulatory environment is
very restrictive and it keeps people out
and it's kept out a lot of these big
players but they're they're coming
they're gonna be here whoa okay so could
it then be safe to say that with
emerging markets progressing that the
the smaller emerging market slowly
thinks the regulatory frameworks opening
up it becomes there's more funding that
comes in and the funding can come in
from some of the bigger players driving
up valuations so this is kind of a
reoccurring theme that comes up in the
more and more jobs open up the economy
continues to grow the people get more
work from it people get like infer the
benefits of a cannabis it could be for
textile purposes for medicinal purposes
all of the benefits of that wellness
side and so then die so then the this is
so with with the big players coming in
driving up evaluations and also it's
kind of interesting thinking about like
the little combinatory
of like Canada or Israel or the United
States or like other even more
constriction estates like a Chinese
market that what would it look like for
1.4 billion people to gain access to
cannabis there's a wellness if it
happens well you know we talked about
this on our panel today one of the
investors talked about how the the
Chinese hemp markets are really kind of
the exciting new frontier out there in
terms of the sheer scale and the ability
of you know the ground conditions the
labour force I mean they will be
producing probably a majority of the
world's hemp one day whether it will be
exported back here and you know in
China's been doing this in other
agricultural markets as well even though
it you know this may be an evergreen
moment in time this interview but I mean
if we eat snap to the trade war that's
going on right now you know it's about
Chinese buying enough of our soybeans or
I don't think the Chinese are gonna be
buying our help I think the Chinese are
gonna be growing their own hemp and
that's you know that is part of the
excitement of this being a global market
in interestingly enough potentially used
for the purposes of us like as an
economic commodity and not necessarily
as an industrial commodity and not
necessarily as a traditional consumption
yes
Wow so could be banned in that sense as
a consumption and could be hard enough
hard to know that would be also crazy to
see if a country would do something
regulatory like that where it would just
be for an industrial commodity and not
for think about some of the Far Eastern
medicines though I mean think about what
people in this country have adopted in
terms of non-pharmaceutical wellness
products that are originated from China
I mean we're talking about things like
ginkgo and and butBut if you go into a
lot of the wellness stores holistic
medicine Eastern medicines are I mean I
would think this would be kind of a
symbiotic dynamic in China I realize
China is going to be highly regulating
any consumer product and consumer
you know access points but I absolutely
think that hemp products for consumption
and for wellness and you know
cannabinoid you know research and
development for these products even in
non THC I think is is it to me it makes
sense with based upon where China has
come from on these non pharmacological
medicines so ok let's do yeah we just
came back from partnership interviews in
China and we loved our experience there
and it would be so cool to see how maybe
a more collaborative and harmonious
relationship with a with something like
cannabis could happen around the
different countries and their frameworks
around the world so this question is
then about oh there's a couple more
couple more questions this one is on
moving into like let's say like a decade
down the line regulatory frameworks have
opened up the old codes are archived and
the new codes are implemented now maybe
it's even a very serious opening up of
of the the micro investment side for for
young shortchange dogs to come in for a
hundred thousand one hundred or a
thousand dollar investments into into
these organizations does it seem like
then that that is and like the job
market and the way that people could
even though AI comes in and does things
like take away some of the work around
maybe retail or automotive or
manufacturing and these other industries
call centers and stuff but does it open
up jobs in cannabis what do those look
like what do you do well I I think if
this develops the way people want it to
develop the unfortunate part of that is
it's it's going there's gonna be you
know technology is also going to drive a
lot of disruption yeah so it's no
different than a lot of consumer
products and it's going to make the
supply chain more efficient it's going
to make the the marketing and the
distribution and the consumer you know
understand the consumer tastes and
preferences and and and obviously
building data pools that are based upon
consumption trends
and that's just to understand who's
gonna sell what to who but in terms of
production in terms of distribution and
in terms of you know all the logistics
in ERP I mean so it's good and the bad
news here is we want we want those
cannabis jobs at some point if we want
this to evolve to get disrupted it has
to happen and so what makes the cannabis
industry so interesting right now is as
a consumer product it's it's popping up
on the shelves or through Amazon going
down the same road and sitting not
necessarily right next to on the shelves
as you know Oreo cookies and and you
know Wheaties but but I mean consumer
products are being distributed to
consumers in very sophisticated ways
through very sophisticated means based
upon very sophisticated consumer
marketing research based upon data so
why is kind of is going to be any
different in fact that's why it's moving
at warp speed because while those
technological developments and and
pinpoint focused on certain industries
and disruption are changing other
industries cannabis is being born and
those things are changing cannabis at
the same time so it's moving twice as
fast and that's that's good news but
it's probably scary and it's hard to you
can't think the cannabis is gonna be
able to kind of keep this holistic you
know kind of organic localized community
that's not disrupted by big business so
wow we've not seen emerging markets rise
with artificial intelligence until now
and so now it'll be cool to see what
those two rising simultaneously look
like also on it especially like this is
a really interesting your perspective
here if then as emerging markets have
historically risen big dogs come in
swoop majority of initial investments
and profits from that and later makes it
easier for smaller dogs to come in and
get maybe bread crumbs let's say right
um would you then say that the future
it'll be really important to do things
like open up the investment for the
small people around the world to do
these micro investments ten
a hundred bucks a thousand bucks in to
try and spread the the fruits yeah I
think I think if you think about you
know different types of landing
platforms and minoo VC kind of you know
for the masses raised platforms we've
seen a bunch of in in pretty traditional
investment and and NBC private equity
worlds I think expecting that to happen
in cannabis is is appropriate and it
will I think one of the reasons why we
like the sec and one of the reasons why
there is regulation for all investors of
all asset classes is because you know
with with more immature industries with
highly speculative stuff where there is
a lot of hysteria and there is a lot of
public interest and there's not a lot of
information this is actually these are
the times we want our government to
protect us I know a lot of us would
rather have less government not probably
one of them but I think to expect
cannabis investing for the masses for
the small dogs to to take the place of
the same way they can get involved in
and you know some kind of a
technological process or be investing in
Tesla or you know whatever it is in
things that seem to be leading edge and
exciting socially conscious that's all
great and I think that will happen it
kind of is I just think we industry in
the capital markets and the the
investment infrastructure needs to get
more sophisticated before you can let
these nickels and dimes and small dogs
in and I think you're doing it it's it's
in there it's in their best interest I
think yeah yeah and it's just difficult
to figure out how an SEC would possibly
be able to make it so that $10
investments can go in our hundred dollar
investments and so actually private
companies have won and taken on the
initiative to buy in 50 million bucks in
to read of the big SpaceX's and then
redistribute outright $50 bids into the
pool I think that stuff so awesome
democratizing financial investment I
think is such an important part of
financial literacy
eradicating poverty yeah and uplifting
people around the world do stuff yeah
yeah the two last questions that we ask
all of our guests on the show first one
is
do you think we're in a simulation you
and I yeah are we in a simulation now
we're having a conversation my friend
we're just you know but you tell me are
we in a simulation this is a very
interesting question that we like
polling what are we defining a
simulation this is another great
question how do you define it yeah
because let's think about technology
okay technology itself getting towards
super intelligence is able to create
simulations of civilizations of again
just big bangs and universes and watch
their evolution and how is that not
already what this potentially it is well
we are I think what's wonderful about
this industry is there are some elements
as we get into both science and and how
people are processing information and
the impact of cannabis and cannabinoids
and some of the sciences we don't really
know what's going on one of the powerful
and exciting parts of it's a sub
vertical everything we're talking about
is that from a science and research
perspective the power of the plant and
the power of the usages are you know so
being able to actually get into literal
simulations of truly where we can go
with the technology as part of you know
why I think a lot of us are here so you
know I I think there's there's a literal
translation to this there's a figurative
translation to this for an industry that
we're kind of trying to figure out where
we're going and and the implications
it's changing society on some level
let's let so a change medicine
let's also tie that into what we were
just mentioning how could there's a sec
there's code there's the counting code
there's the say fact code right what if
you deployed that code update in a
simulation of the United States economy
and watched its evolution for five years
before you actually did it in the
physical world so that's the kind of
stuff potentially that well could
leverage with the technologies I think
we should we shall we will we probably
are but but in the same way in my first
job out of Business School I went
through a training program at you
yes and they gave us market simulators
and they gave us different inputs yeah
and and to see you know how we were
gonna manage and assess you know assets
during you know this this macroeconomic
number hits the tape what our markets
gonna do and so I mean I think we can do
that but it's in a vacuum I mean I and I
realized simulations have become a lot
more sophisticated so even the market
simulations that one might do at a
training program at UBS coming out of
school today is different than what's
probably seeming pretty archaic to the
one I was taking a time that seemed very
innovated and edgy but decades from now
but but but there's no question whatever
we can simulate today is is going to
give us information on tomorrow
accepting it as gospel I think is is
would be scary in the last question we
like asking is what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world the
most beautiful thing at my family I mean
I you know they the relationships that
people have with each other I think
growing into you know coexistence in the
human
I mean people at different times in
their lifecycle are more or less
comfortable in their own skin and
watching people and having people get
comfortable in their skin together and
growing together but that comes that to
me happens in a family environment right
so I'm a father I've got kids my kids
are you know six and 11 and to me that's
the most beautiful thing in the world
because unfortunately some of the some
of the the the oxidants of the world
haven't hit these kids yet and and you
know you you try to you try to keep that
as pure as possible but I I really do
think to me the things that make me
happiest are human interactions so yes
my family yes you know people friends
whatever communities and so that to me
is where beauties derived I love that
the relationships and then also that
the comfortability and the skin evolving
over time yep in our own passion that
people change people evolve I mean they
evolve as people they evolve in their
comfort levels in society and hopefully
for the better I mean I think yeah you
know as a 20 year old I was like very
different yeah yeah yeah I was really
cool but I was really different I'm just
kidding yeah so I thought a lot a lot
more time to have soaked in the reality
that we're in and become wiser and get
knowledgeful and yeah and this has been
such a pleasure I thank you for coming
on the show really appreciate thanks
everyone for tuning in
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking check out the
links below to Tim's work check out the
links below to a new West Summit support
the organization's the artists the
entrepreneurs the leaders around the
world when you believe and you can
support simulation our links are below
as well and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world you love you very much thanks for
tuning in and we'll see you soon
[Music]